[Music]
this week we've got TP crisis arrested
Vicki and elevator karma with the fancy
Egyptian and only a bomb yeah there we
go
many one yeah as a for our first story
did you guys hear about Taiwan's toilet
paper crisis no you're their ambassador
in this room what happened oh yes
so okay excuse me I have the attention
everybody just to let you know from the
Taipei to the cow song there's no more
toilet paper so if you need to take a
[ __ ] I'm so sorry
how does this happen why is there a
shortage of the Sun because supermarkets
everyone ate see get over that mad diary
[Laughter]
every other day I trust each other it
gives you diarrhea you thought it was
gonna be great
I like stinky foods like durian [ __ ]
love it what's golf about Taiwan I don't
know if you guys know this but when the
garbage truck comes into town it plays a
song mm-hmm so everyone will they hear
it and then everyone runs out with the
trash and they get really hungry they
throw it up throw it up yeah go get
stinky tofu dr. Davis what have you miss
oh you just bring it out like everyone
brings their trash out at the same time
I mean little bags better than Mexico's
just on the floor I know there's a couch
but what if you're not home evil ties
issues yeah I think it Mexico no I don't
think it's every day I don't remember it
stuff like that
you're the Mexican ambassador the group
I'm the chicken ambassador yeah when I
lived there I remember
but anyway so supermarket says that
prices of toilet paper would be
increasing by 10 to 30 percent by
mid-march so everyone just started
panicking and just buying up all the
your family doesn't didn't tell you
anything about it no I don't see why you
would talk about that would be hilarious
if they called you like it was an
epidemic like send me some right now
right now we need the toilet paper right
now it's very serious I'm imagining like
you know remember the video of the the
Chinese people at the buffet [ __ ]
fighting over crab legs they cleaned out
all this door you might go I hate like
very politely doh they're just like I
find it dope that Taiwan has a costume
there's a bunch of Costco's there
there's Costco's all over Asia yes and
before that a Costco they had this thing
called kara for all the time oh I've
seen this I think it's in the your java
foo is the Chinese way of saying there's
a Costco in Japan I imagine Dara Costco
looks just exactly like alhambra yeah
she's right here well there you go the
layouts the same wherever you go how
much you want to bet inside that Costco
- it's 93 degrees and if you got jackets
on how much you want to bet their
parking job they're all taking up three
spaces at once how much you want to bet
all those people about nothing you know
how the Costco in the Hawaii has pokey
yeah I wonder what they got and they're
stinky tofu yeah but before even lining
up outside Costco before customers you
know what's happening there Asian ass is
buying it so they can sell it that's
what's happening yeah they're gonna do
it like the iPhones when they buy it
over here and ship it over there how
much more expensive is it gonna be 10 to
30% oh yeah for sure
30% I'm gonna make five I think Cosmo
that the paper out there is like what
like five bucks that big-ass pack I made
that up it could be 50 speaking of you
know how like they they buy [ __ ] here
and they sell it over there I just heard
about a dude that spends like a 50,000
every supreme draw for people to wait in
line for them he gives you so within if
it's like ten thousand or more you have
to pay a luxury tax with some [ __ ] he
gives a kid in line nine thousand nine
hundred fifty dollars here's a thousand
you can keep go buy as much [ __ ] as
possible and they bring it back to me
and he ships it and he said I mean it's
like 80 50 million last week and he's
only spending fifty thousand on kids at
[ __ ] paid wait
d million thank you kidnap Jessie clean
yeah dude
like just also have like supreme [ __ ] to
sell in China you're not that's so crazy
I had a I had a friend that sells baby
he smuggles baby products to China and
he makes millions
if this smuggle that because it's
illegal technically you're not supposed
to be doing it for business oh yeah do
you have to go through customs and all
that it's a black market baby product
because people in China don't trust
their own products I would either so
they're like there's gonna be led in
this baby formula oh how they get led in
the weirdest places they use the same
factory that makes paint with I don't
know this is Chinese people it's
whatever's convenient so I I'm in
college I still run at eBay business
with my buddy and he would give me like
this catalogue he would ask me what do I
think would sell in the same catalog
because it's a plastics company
there's toothbrushes dildos drum sets
jump ropes kids slides all made at the
same place so next two kids slides
there's like a big fat dick yeah so you
could probably buy like [ __ ] a little
pony with like [ __ ] juice on it I gets
crazy dude that's so tight that would be
so [ __ ] funny if like that the plate
they accidentally mixed up they're like
they're selling like jungle gyms right
but the pegs are dildos familiar that
doesn't make sense something in the
millions bouquet it's a lot of money
they could play [ __ ] tug of war with
that [ __ ] yeah what you see but or is
not funny at all
[Laughter]
you're losing me you're losing me I love
this cool jump rope online that once it
goes over like it right in front of you
it shows you the counter of how you buy
and then you connect it to your phone
and it keeps a counter but like it shows
it like as it goes so I can't even see
the jump rope with a jump rope but it
had like numbers that's dough that's
besides the point
anyway here we go does it reset when you
trip your leg cuz I do that a lot mass
on it when you trip does dough negative
one so fry next story do you guys
remember that white girl and it thinks
that she's black
Rachel Dolezal weighs a lot leader of
the n-double a-c-p Australian yeah that
one's [ __ ] dumb as [ __ ] wait wait
early aware like she like she looks dumb
as [ __ ] she's like painted her face
black everything will be like everything
like no no this girl she's a 17 year old
chick we've talked about her before
oh they're dumb little slow Vicki
there's a catch me outside I don't know
why I don't why you're here yeah you
know like when you're in your teeth gets
dry and smelling your lips get stuck
upside down [ __ ] every day yeah got
that cleft palate [ __ ]
thank so [ __ ] up [ __ ] [ __ ] she
does a girl Mouse without the girls
she's a good poor man's grills you know
I actually need to see this video what
video her whatever the good you remember
she she uh she was talking about how
she's part black and then she did that
uh ancestry DNA thing she's actually
figure out [ __ ] up but she's dumbest she
got famous by doing the ching-chong
thing too right so she's making
headlines again because she got arrested
in a mall right when she was getting
arrested she started yelling black lives
matter what did she do so she ended up
kicking a police officer why don't but
she kicked a police officer in North
Carolina and so they arrested home on
you [ __ ] read her friends were [ __ ]
Grim Reaper you Grim Reaper friends are
recording thank you Joe a clip wait has
to a black officer yes she kicks a black
officer it goes black lives matter [ __ ]
she kicked him and then said that why
don't I be with him because there's
multiple police officers arms are you
yeah young here we go she's crazy
you realize in her photos he's sticking
out to her defects too big for her mouth
well what is she percentage of black to
be like 12 is but you know why she's
transparent right now she has two white
parents oh she's only black when a black
big is it her I'd be scared to get your
dick sucked by those things huh looks
like she'll straight to that [ __ ] yeah
so her boyfriend also got arrested in
the same altercation he wife it you
would like I owe my god I'm so when she
wrote the black card immediately and
we'll community Shutts amount shun soon
apparently during the scuffle of
something happened to his nose and so
she's claiming that they mistreated him
and so that's why she was saying that
lives matter for her boyfriend to a
black cop yeah that's the funniest [ __ ]
on earth but you kicked the cop you dumb
[ __ ] it's not like they're doing this
out of nowhere what is this like some
shitty initiation to our [ __ ]
baby-sitters club I love it when people
like in the middle of a cop like taking
someone down they go what are you doing
like do you think in the middle of that
they're gonna say you're right right
yeah I'm sorry I [ __ ] up like the [ __ ]
people [ __ ] because look it's so
stupid because of the whole beat
video-recording thing like you guys know
I just watch a lot of trash on YouTube
but there's this video of this cop and
it was a it was a Brazilian Jujitsu
breakdown thing and the guy the cop has
clearly been taught like you just don't
eat is somebody done with non-lethal
force but you just hear these people in
the bag I'm recording you I'm recording
like for what he's not doing anything
you know but they're trying to get them
do something wrong well he wasn't doing
anything wrong and the guy was actually
reaching for the cops gun Oh instead of
helping the [ __ ] cop they're saying
that they're trying to
criminate the cop it's like you'll help
the cop out you know what I think I'm
part of it's like they just was like if
I get a good video the news will come
and ask
it's terrible dude viral yeah it smells
like officially smells like warm mail
and I better make it back Oh 30 it has a
spilled foundation in it I [ __ ]
guarantee you guys a messy-ass make a
bag what do you smell like a soft-boiled
egg
I do wish she embraced like the positive
black stereotypes is just claiming that
she's black
but doing what she went to a Baptist
Church and like she like seeing those
games and like really hard for to say no
she claims that she's black but then
like okay she transracial transracial ah
so her idea of black people is this
[ __ ] garbage that's [ __ ] dude
that's racist that's racist right
that's like let me let me like eat
watermelon fried chicken get some corn
rolls and then be trans ratio that's why
when people tell tell people like oh
you're acting black what's black let me
know tell me what black is what acting
black is cuz there's all kinds of
different people I want to see like I'd
be translational with a Chinese person
that should be huh yeah so there was a
trans ratio oh he drove like one of
those tuk tuks those [ __ ] those
three-wheeled mopeds that like you would
see in Thailand that one was so mixed up
he doesn't even know yeah Phillip like
you didn't even know Filipino he was
just random [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah hi I got
it all mixed up yeah it's pretty
terrible no be get a lot of people going
back on what you were saying the fact
that she perpetuates the negative
stereotypes of black culture like she's
been called out on that a lot and so
that's why she has all these haters you
know what though I love weaves I'm a
hundred percent supportive of weaves I
want more white people to mimic Asians I
want more white people to embrace it and
because Williams count all agencies
Japanese I think it's Asian /all rien so
Marilyn
I were at a foot action and I saw this
kid like white kid like bleach little
face like pink lipgloss large oversized
pink hoodie like in the kpop that I was
like yo I'd never saw one in person you
know you could tell he's like he really
loves like k-pop guys you know whenever
I think of waves I just think I'm like
sweaty dudes and waifu pillows and no
this guy's like legit that guy wanted to
be like a k-pop star to the man who's
the good-looking weaves to well he I he
looked like he was dying because me make
it's fun yeah like I was like oh [ __ ]
dude like yeah I'm all for it man when I
when I'm in Japan and I see all these
foreigners like wearing Japanese clothes
and I'm like hell yeah that's dope let's
don't learn more about the culture
people are not see yeah I don't want to
be like don't be a culture vulture I'm
like no I want you to [ __ ] see me as
a god I want to [ __ ] wanna be me like
that's awesome but what about when they
take it and they don't even give the
credit to where they still looking up to
us I don't give a [ __ ] because you know
even now like they're doing those kimono
jackets
that's just Douglas gojong oh yeah it's
a last story there was this young boy
that got Instant Karma when you have
Instant Karma me too I love Instant
Karma if it's warm feeling inside
because you feel it you feel it like you
are the piece of [ __ ] and then it
happens you're like oh but UK like oh
yes like when someone does something
illegal on the freeway or something and
then a cops just right behold yeah or
when they like hit something we do
something better than hit it you're like
oh yeah it's like a fine boy
all right here we go it's even a touch
it to tell me was something there for
like six hours I hope so his desperate
jump like thank you cuz you got to his
floor he was ready to get out that's
what you realize I hope it wasn't in his
house he just really impressed by the
height of his piss pretty impressive and
on top of that how much you want to bet
that guy's like 52 years old he's like a
senior citizen even even in that case he
still had a really nice it was like good
stream he went he goes he went for the
bottom button he went oh I saw his pee
running out too so I was getting lower
and lower
but then he was trying to compensate my
[ __ ] shock I've never tested the
height of my pee have tested the
distance before why did this seem though
however why would I watch that
immediately I thought of you me I think
are you doing that as a kid I feel like
you peed on a lot of things when you're
a kid keep beating bottles me why are we
done looking at Joe why we don't looking
at Joe I don't think that's his type I
don't think I never peed in an elevator
but I've peed on other things inside of
a bathrooms like for example handle or
one thing that's really fun
this is pretty [ __ ] up but if you've
ever done this as a kid you'll know the
glory of this so have you guys ever
watched a manga time but have you guys
ever taken the cover of a toilet paper
no the full rolls there right gets all
stuffy what do you mean I've seen it
I've seen if you ever see like in the
bathroom that there's a toilet paper
full of piss the kid pissed on you not
me when I was six
yeah when I was like in free grade
second grade I would pee like you know
we're on the stall is or like that yeah
and I know where the handle is I would
try to pee as high as possible so the P
will drip into the like that from the
top behind this what is going on did you
used to pee with your friends no I
couldn't wait to pee with my friends
that was like when one kid was like I
gotta go pee I'm like oh I'll come too
cuz I wanted to cross P with them and
then someone else will be like oh me too
and if we were all any of your friends
ever stopping me like why no everyone
was excited you know what it's like
bonding David wait can't wait to pee
with you
well can we cross peas later that's cuz
like what the [ __ ] - all for this now
huh an elementary school that never
happened no I never I'm not you have you
and your friends try to see who could be
the furthest away so you start the P and
you start walking back and then you try
to keep staying in there yeah the only
thing girls do at that age is we look at
each other's boobs like who's got bigger
yeah I never did any of that gross [ __ ]
in first grade like elementary school
yeah I know my middle school for me yeah
well because my my best friend at that
time she had boobs already so I was like
what how did you get them so big and she
goes I think it's because I eat a lot of
carrots cut to Geo just [ __ ]
shoveling tell me it was Tomatoes cuz
the same thing must be like a Mexican
thing or some [ __ ] so what happened to
you my nipple on some grass and they're
[ __ ] banned from ice is the cucumber
from The Brady Bunch
when was it the growth Marcia like she
would bark she would be doing this like
to try to make her boobs are bigger
I remember being little to like come on
boobs oh yeah oh I see I see the pikers
on my other
[Music]